ever since sebastian stan emerged on the
hollywood scene in captain america the
first avenger
marvel and star wars fans have noticed
that the bucky barnes betrayer bears a
striking resemblance to a young mark
hamill
who you may recall from this small
science fiction movie from about 40
something years ago
here's some money go see a star war
hamill's run as luke skywalker began
with the first star wars film in 1977
and runs up through his recent
appearance in the mandalorian season 2
finale which first aired in 2020
the stan hamill resemblance has been
observed for years hamill himself
tweeted in 2017
accompanied by side by side photos of
stan and himself where they look like
almost the same person
sorry to disappoint you but i refuse to
say sebastian stan
i am your father even though in fact i
am ammo's digitally de-aged mandalorian
cameo only increased fan excitement for
a theoretical young luke skywalker movie
or disney plus show
and sebastian stan is fan's first choice
to take over the role
one destiny-minded star wars fan wrote
on twitter the existence of sebastian
stan is itself a clarion call to tell
more of luke skywalker's story
sometimes the decision isn't commercial
sometimes the stars just align and the
way forward presents itself
stan is currently promoting his new
marvel limited series the falcon and the
winter soldier and reporters have asked
about the idea of him playing luke
skywalker
he said he'd love to but only with the
blessing of the real luke skywalker stan
said on good morning america last week
if mark hamill calls me personally to
tell me that he
feels inclined to uh to
to share this role with me then i'll
believe it hamill has now responded to
stan's statement in an interesting way
mark hamill neither endorsed nor
rejected stan's apparent willingness to
inherit the force
he explained that whatever decision gets
made about the future of luke skywalker
is out of his hands
hamill tweeted a post by the hollywood
reporter staff writer ryan parker about
stan's statement that hamill would have
to sign off on the casting for him to
accept the role
and threw some cold water on the notion
that the green lightsaber would be
passed in such a way
because the reality is that mark hamill
is not a producer of star wars and
therefore doesn't have a say in any
major casting decisions
he doesn't really even have any input on
the direction luke took in the movies
hamill wrote this assumes i have any say
in casting decisions at lucasfilm when
in fact
i don't hamill is perhaps coyly
misinterpreting stan's statement
both actors know any casting decision is
lucasfilms to make
stan is just saying that he wouldn't
feel right taking on the role of luke
skywalker without mark hamill's blessing
should the offer hypothetically be
presented
hamill may not be a star wars decision
maker but his opinion about the state of
the franchise matters to fans
and hamel is keeping his opinion to
himself for now should luke skywalker
ever be recast with sebastian stan or
anyone else we can look to what harrison
ford said about alden ehrenreich taking
up the mantle of han solo and solo for
an idea of how hamel might react
according to yahoo news ford said aaron
reich was a wonderful guy very sweet and
a very good actor and he was delighted
by the choice though it would be a
little weird to see someone else be han
solo
if the notoriously cranky board was that
publicly positive it seems likely that
the upbeat hammel will be even more
effusive about a new luke skywalker
when and if that happens check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about star wars
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one